over the first five days
13 people were murdered in the nation's
capital okay the city has recorded as
many as 161 homicides this year a 28
increase over last year more than the
total number of killings that occurred
in all of 2018 and it's on track for the
deadliest year in two decades now we've
been asking when enough is enough when
are these
democrat-dominated cities going to wake
up well there's a sign of Hope in
Washington DC of all places where things
may be beginning to crack D.C councilman
Treyon white who represents one of the
poorest parts of the district held a
press conference today and asked for
something that former president Trump
recommended for urban America years ago
I've spoken with the DC National Guard
know that police alone is not getting
done we are clearly in a war zone
you haven't been here until we restore
order in our community
and love in our community in the
presence of God back in our community
we'll be here over and over and over
again
now the Biden appointed U.S attorney in
D.C Matthew Graves has been overly
aggressive in coming after January 6
defendants we know that story but as to
the city's runaway crime well he refused
to prosecute 67 percent of the cases
brought to him
so could this actually please be a
turning point are Democrats finally
waking up to the effects of their own
policies it's a disaster well only time
will tell
but I did tell you yesterday about that
viral video from California speaking of
crime up to 7-Eleven store clerks who
had it with one deranged Thief who was
suspected of stealing from their store
twice in a 24-hour period Well he came
back for a third time that same day and
this is what happened
there's nothing you could do man tell
you about police
ain't nothing you can do man tell police
come on don't do that don't do that man
don't do that
all right
[Applause]
okay there were reports yesterday and
the day before that those two clerks
were being investigated for assault but
the D.A confirmed today that the only
person they're investigating is a
suspect who reportedly threatened to
shoot one of the workers tonight we're
learning what went on behind the scenes
of that riveting video joining me the
man who captured that moment when those
two clerks finally had had enough
Lewis Dita Benton a local business owner
in Stockton California Dida
um what happened precisely before you
started that video
well I was there to get gas in the Red
Bull so I was already at the register I
usually use digital uh wallets so I was
I had my phone already in position
and so once uh this guy with a blue mask
walks in he's kind of coming towards my
way I was kind of a little startled I
just uh I just kind of was like what's
going on but I seen you bypassed me went
around the counter and then I got a 55
gallon drum
now your own store
um I guess you're not surprised to watch
this in a way because you have as in
your own store been vandalized
yes it was broken into uh they broke the
window uh went in and took items out and
then uh
actually they broke the window in the
morning to see if the alarms go off and
then waited encased it and then went in
and took stuff and came back and forth
dude the editorial board of the Modesto
Bee says that the 711 Clerks
went too far saying that the guy was
being you know thrashing the guy with a
big Rod viciously and repeatedly is not
the lawful response Street Justice may
be popular in movies or among frustrated
citizens but it has no place in society
blah blah blah well Dina you were there
you agree with that uh bleeding heart
assessment
uh that that's a real hard assessment
there they just had a stick and they
just was uh you know they um they were
protecting a store
um they didn't hit the guy above the
waist it was all below the waist I
believe everything they've done was
courageous and they was Brave for it I
just didn't want anything to happen uh
for anyone to lose their life or the
guys started getting more emotionally
involved for them to go to jail
well data you know in the in California
which is the state I love I love
Northern California I know exactly where
you are in Stockton I just drove through
about a month and a half ago on the way
out to San Andreas so I know it well
um but when is enough when is enough
enough because you all are being just
brutalized or hassled or inconvenienced
or you know you know totally you know
destroyed by this criminal element when
is enough enough yes yeah well enough is
enough it's been it's been uh enough a
long time ago
um now this video uh comes out uh these
two courageous men uh when they have
Protected Their store so this is a
display of enough is enough and uh you
know we just have to change the policies
you know we have to vote uh we got to
figure out a better way and hopefully uh
like you said Democrats uh understand
what's going on
is it time to get serious with crime and
put people away instead of continuing
the revolving door here
yes um well this gentleman uh I guess
this is the third time that day
um as of now um I know he's in custody
um he do have a long rap seat
um so you know Justice uh is gonna be
served and and is served at this point
so I guess today will that day was the
bad day for him
the video hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else